everybody welcome back hey we have
monaco jackson with us in studio happy
belated mother's day
oh thank you and i heard you guys did
some wonderful things for your moms this
weekend
yes we did yeah y'all are good kiddos
they're gonna love you forever who's the
favorite who's the favorite in the
family oh my little brother
he's the angel he can do no wrong john i
think you're the fave are you the fade
oh absolutely even if you weren't you
say yeah
oh yeah for sure no i it's i have a
certificate of it in my house yeah
favorite son monica you know his mom's
at home watching
she has her own thoughts yeah she might
dispute that i know y'all gonna be in
trouble
hey 6 42 thanks guys i appreciate it
according to
a recent report from bloomberg now it
disturbed me folks so just pay attention
here just a little bit
1.4 million mothers who left the
workforce due to the
pandemic are struggling to get back in
but it makes no sense especially since
the job market is wide open right
here in las vegas it seems like every
other day even here on eight news now
we're hearing about a job fair we're
hearing about jobs opening the casinos
are hiring
and can't find people so let's dig in a
little deeper joining me now to talk
more about this is unlv economics
professor
see jeffrey waddups he wants me to call
him professor waddups
good morning to you or jeff i'm not
doing jeff you earned that professor
so thank you so much for being here
professor let me let me start out by
letting everybody know what you do
specifically you teach labor and
economics so
you dig in deep to these numbers and
these problems
what is going on and why women in
particular and
going even deeper mothers
well okay that i teach this labor
economics class and we deal with these
issues all the time so
uh the first thing i think about when
when i think about
what's going on in the labor market and
why people not might not be going back
to work
is wages and it just seems to me
like the same wage that attracted enough
labor pre-pandemic is not doing the
trick
post-pandemic so in
if if employers want to get enough
workers they may just have to raise the
wage
and there are a couple of reasons why
that might be the case
first working conditions aren't the same
so you can kind of think about wages and
working conditions being part of the
same compensation package
if if working conditions have
deteriorated
then the wage has to go up to get enough
workers
and you you can you can think about what
kind of
working conditions have changed i mean
people might not think that it's safe at
work because of
covid people might think that
it's they don't want to go fight the
customers to wear their masks
you know that kind of thing yeah and so
also so so that's kind of what i'm
thinking about
yeah it's and in particular in the
article um it said that minority moms
are falling behind even more so in job
gains now as more and more companies
seek
to diversify their workforce why would
any minority group be at a disadvantage
especially since we have all felt the
pain of the pandemic
why would anybody be falling behind well
that's one of the one of the sad
commentaries about our labor market
is minority workers and
workers and female workers have have had
a lot more trouble than say white male
workers and the unemployment rates
generally
especially for african-american male
workers are
basically twice as high as that of
others so
of of white workers so
yeah i mean and you know
what with the uh with what we've been
seeing recently
uh with uh black lives matter and so on
we we kind of know that there's this
this racist element in society i mean
it's just
it's just there yeah and it manifests
itself in the labor market as higher
unemployment rates
uh but you but you're right about one
thing you i mean
it's if we could if the economy is
booming
if we run the economy like white hot
then that is good for everybody right
right and we can do that i think it's
happening here in las vegas right now
let me get to this final question for
you we know that employers you know they
screen for work gaps but is it fair in
the age of covet
for that aspect to even play a part in
the hiring process for moms or anybody
else for that matter but
we're focusing on moms and that's what
the article was talking about
well yeah i mean no it's not fair
uh and and it's not even reasonable
because
the thing that happened with covet is
all those things in society that allowed
mothers to go to work
suddenly went away and
and and uh that that was through no
fault of mothers
or anyone else so it's not right
that that mothers would have to pay for
that
uh although
uh there's this whole strand of
literature out there that talks about
the motherhood wage penalty
so on mother's day that's one of the
things we have to recognize
is that mother's sacrifice their uh
prosperity in the labor market for their
kids absolutely
yeah there's nothing like a mother
nothing like a mother's love so happy
mother's day to all of you out there
struggling to get back in
hey i feel your pain and a lot of folks
are working trying to help you
get back into the mainstream professor
wadups thank you so much i appreciate it
all right thank you for having me
absolutely have a good one and
so folks uh hey tune in to mondays with
monica
on uh oh we have a job board here hey if
you're looking for work
i forgot about this we put together a
list of companies that are hiring right
now just head on over to eight newsnow
dot com
and click on the job board tab and don't
forget to catch my moj show facebook
live tonight
at seven of course it is news you can
use and the las vegas culture we're
gonna replay
our interview as well so moms i hope
that helped you out just a little bit to
understand a little bit but
sherry i don't know about you but i
remember when i had my son instead of
taking my full 12 weeks of maternity
leave
i was asked by somebody to take only
eight
oh and i obliged did you really and
looking back
yeah looking back i feel like that time
with my newborn
baby was stolen sure yeah i took my full
12.
goodbye regrets yeah yeah the time is
short it's precious
absolutely goes fast yeah so well good
luck to all moms out there who are
trying to balance
the child care and getting back to work
it's it's working
it's rough